[Music]
health care in America is expensive in
part because consumers do not play the
same role that they do in other sectors
prices are high and patients get many
services that will not improve their
health consumers will be able to shop
for non-emergency medical care only when
it is easy to compare prices on an
apples-to-apples basis in today's
complex an opaque market that's not
possible the federal government is the
only entity with a reach and capacity to
unlock pricing for consumers that will
require two steps first the government
should establish a required pricing list
for common interventions the key is
standardization to ensure comparability
across competing suppliers second
Congress should require insurance plans
to pay for all out-of-network services
on the pricing list at their average
payments for those services consumers
would get to keep the savings when
getting care with prices below the
amounts paid by the insurers these steps
would make it easy for consumers to shop
for services and thus would encourage
providers to set their prices as low as
possible is it possible for consumers to
shop for medical services under the
right circumstances let us know in our
poll also let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI